interesting set of stats 86 percent of
women say that they want a man to make
the first move 50 of men are scared of
making the first move for being seen as
creepy and 20 of gen Zed say that a man
approaching a woman in person always or
usually constitutes harassment so you
have a very difficult Circle to square
here you have women who still want to be
approached you have men who know that if
they don't approach nothing's going to
happen but if they do approach they're
scared of being seen as creepy they're
concerned that they're going to either
upset this girl or that they're going to
be part of some metoo Scandal and then
you have a societal pressure lots of men
are checking out of the world we need to
ask not just why aren't men opening up
about this what can they do to fix
themselves but structurally how can we
actually help men and I think that a
huge thing is that so many of these
systems are against men whether we're
talking about you know Family Court
divorce court now with affirmative
action applying for jobs where a company
would be much happier giving the job to
a woman because then they get to say oh
we hired a woman for this role it's like
sexuality in the tallest seat exactly